I have to ask the bigger picture
question about the two companies
pushing Humanity forward out towards the
Stars blue origin and SpaceX are you
competitors collaborators which and to
what degree well I would say you know
just like the internet is big and there
are lots of winners at all skill levels
I mean there are half a dozen giant
companies the you know the internet has
made but they're a bunch of medium-sized
companies and a bunch small companies
all successful all with profit streams
all driving great customer
experiences um that's what we want to
see in space that kind of dynamism and
space is Big there's room for a bunch of
winners and it's going to happen at all
skill levels and so you know SpaceX is
going to be successful for sure I want
blue origin to be successful and I hope
there are another you know five
companies right behind
us but you know I spoke to Elon a few
times recently about you about blue
origin and he was very positive about
you as a person and very supportive of
all the efforts you've been leading at
Blue what's your thoughts you worked
with a lot of leaders at Amazon at Blue
what's your thoughts about Elon as a
human being and a
leader well I don't really know Elon
very well um you know I know his public
persona but I also know you can't know
anyone by their public
Persona um it's impossible I mean you
may think you do but I guarantee you
don't so I don't really know you know
Elon way better than I do Lex but um in
in terms of his judging by the results
he must be a very capable leader um
there's no way you could have you know
Tesla and SpaceX without being a capable
leader it's
impossible yeah I just I I hope you guys
hang out sometimes Shake hand hands and
sort of um have a kind of friendship
that would Inspire just the entirety of
humanity cuz what you're doing is like
one of the big
Grand challenges ahead for Humanity well
I agree with you and I think in a lot of
these um Endeavors we're very
like-minded yeah so I think you I think
you I'm not saying we're identical but I
think we're very likeminded and so I you
know I I I love that idea